bonsoir et bienvenue pour votre journal
d'information locale il est 18 heures si
vous nous suivez en direct on ce lundi
16 février voici les principaux titres
la communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines réfléchit
actuellement à son budget et pour son
président la situation est inédite et
particulièrement délicate il va falloir
réaliser plusieurs millions d'économies
dans quelques jours les mondiaux de
cyclisme sur piste l'organisation se
prépare à accueillir le public les
champions peaufinent leur préparation
l'heure est aux derniers réglages et
puis invité emmanuel plutôt nouvelle
présidente est de créer active
association dont le mot d'ordre est
entreprendre au féminin ses priorités et
son regard sur la situation actuelle
quelques images pour débuter celle de ce
paris début 1900 ce sont les photos qui
ont circulé toute la journée sur les
réseaux sociaux des quartiers de la
capitale totalement transformé pour le
tournage du nouveau film de roschdy zem
un biopic porté par omar sy son titre
chocolat l'histoire d'un artiste de
cirque noir le trappistes omar sy que
l'on verra d'ici là au cinéma dans
jurassic world sorti au mois de juin on
en vient à l'actualité économique et le
vote du budget de l'agglomération prévue
le 9 avril prochain les conseillers
communautaires se sont d'ores et déjà
réuni jeudi dernier pour discuter autour
du débat d'orientation budgétaire au
coeur des discussions baisse des
dotations 11 millions prévus sur trois
ans un vrai casse tête a reconnu
l'exécutif catherine château le
désengagement de l'état est très
important nous n'avons jamais vu cela
les mots ne sont pas rassurants ce jeudi
soir le président de l'agglomération
michel augeix a décrit une situation
complexe un casse-tête pour l'exécutif
qui prépare son budget pour l'année les
chiffres sont là les dotation
d'intercommunalité seront en diminution
entre 2015 et 2017 de 3,7 millions
d'euros par an soit sur trois ans 11
millions de moins dans les caisses de la
casse qui a ajouté à cela pour cette
année une baisse également de la
dotation globale de fonctionnement
en résumé rien que pour 2015 ce sont 4,7
millions de de perte nette pour les
finances de l'agglomération il va
falloir réduire la voilure a prévenu
l'exécutif qui a promis qu'il n'y aurait
pas d'augmentation d'impôts mais cette
voilure quelle est elle l'agglomération
a lancé trois audits dont les
conclusions ne sont pas encore connus
revoir certaines compétences et se
recentrer sur les principales missions
comme le développement économique
c'est une piste une autre les charges de
personnel elle devrait être réduite 30%
en trois ans est l'un des objectifs
fixés par la nouvelle majorité qui a
déjà évoqué lors d'un précédent conseil
l'importance de la mutualisation l'audit
sur le personnel n'est pas encore
finalisé malgré tout michel logis harold
est dit il des situations surprenantes
entre le travail effectué et le nombre
de personnes pour effectuer ce travail
par contre pas question de revoir
l'aménagement du territoire sur toutes
les communes des projets sont lancés
seront maintenus et soutenu l'opposition
notamment par la voix de l'élu
socialiste de montigny vivien gaasch a
regretté l qu'il dit le manque
d'orientation lors de ce débat il y à
quelques axes mais pas de vraies
propositions françois de ligne et le
maire de bécancour a même estimé que les
conditions du débat n'était pas remplie
et sandrine grand gaube vice-présidente
et et lui attrape s'est interrogé sur la
pertinence de demeurer dans l'exécutif
si at elle expliqué on découvre tout au
moment du vote du budget à ces remarques
le président de l'agglomération a
rétorqué que c'était une situation
historiquement compliqué et qu'il
proposerait un conseil des maires avant
le vote un vote prévu le 9 avril ce soir
là on en saura plus sur les secteurs
concernés par les économies à faire tous
les secteurs seront impactés pas un plus
que l'autre a d'ores et déjà prévenu
michel laugier
et puis c'est cet après midi qu'a lieu
la signature du projet du contrat plan
état région
2015-2020 manuel valls premier ministre
et jean paul huchon président de
l'ile-de-france officialise quelque 7,3
milliards d'euros d'investissements
publics sur cette période notamment pour
l'enseignement supérieur la mobilité
multimodale ou encore la transition
énergétique enfin sachez que benoît
hamon député ps des yvelines ancien
ministre a annoncé hier soir alors qu'il
était l'invité du grand jury rtl le
figaro lci qu'il voterait contre la loi
macron il a répété vouloir je cite un
infléchissement de la politique
économique actuelle on reste dans le
domaine économique justement les clans
vite et de cette édition l'invité de ce
16 février manuel plutôt bon soir vous
êtes la présidente de créactive vous
venez d'être élu mi janvier on va
évoquer vos ambitions auparavant on va
représenter cette association de femmes
chefs d'entreprise pourquoi une
association de femmes chefs
d'entreprises parce que c'est plus
difficile différents qu'un homme chefs
d'entreprise alors l'association a été
créée il ya dix ans pour soutenir les
femmes qui souhaitait entreprendre
est-ce que c'est plus difficile ou pas
ça dépend de l'activité ça dépend de la
situation familiale parfois ce qui est
sûr c'est que les femmes aujourd'hui
entreprennent davantage pour créer leur
emploi que pour créer une entreprise
j'avais des a priori tout de même au
moment de la création de cette
association c'était aussi pour lutter
contre les a priori
notamment je cite pour pour les statuts
mais a affirmé constamment leur
crédibilité lcn difficultés que les
femmes rencontrent tout à fait ça peut
être la crédibilité dans certains
secteurs d'activité ça va être une
difficulté familiale
d'asseoir son projet et de s'affirmer
ce qui est sûr c'est que quand moi j'ai
créé mon entreprise j'ai pas ressenti
cette problématique et
j'avais pas forcément envie de retrouver
une association spécifique pour les
femmes et puis quelqu'un m'a dit si toi
tu n'as pas ressenti de difficultés tu
vas sûrement pouvoir apporter beaucoup
aux femmes qui elles en ressentent donc
c'est un peu ça l'esprit de creative
c'est ensemble ensemble pouvoir se
serrer les coudes certes elle conseille
à des réunions qu'ils sont organisés
tout à fait alors on a une réunion
mensuelle qui est le plus souvent
thématiques avec une personne qui va
intervenir sur un sujet qui concerne les
entrepreneurs en général pas forcément
les femmes d'ailleurs et puis il peut y
avoir des soirées networking
on va échanger les cartes de visite la
majorité des soirées sont ouvertes à
tous même aux personnes qui ne sont pas
membres et une petite minorité des
soirées est réservé aux membres pour
justement échanges et avoir un cadre un
petit peu plus fermé et surtout se
donner des informations sur son carnet d
adresses sur des expériences qu'on a pu
vivre et les autres sont là pour
justement répondre aux questions des
plus les plus jeunes des plus rester les
montres femme vous disiez ouvert aux
gens qui sont pas adhérents les soirées
qui sont ouvertes à tous sont ouvertes
aux hommes également les problématiques
peuvent effectivement être les mêmes
quand on parle de prospection
commerciale de relations clients de
business plans les sommes sont tout à
fait les bienvenus l'objet de
l'association est là bas c'était aider
les femmes mais les hommes qui veulent
aider les femmes sont les bienvenus et
eux aussi vont pouvoir
gagner quelque chose à venir participer
ce soit aux soirées de networking aux
conférences on va juste faire une pause
avant de poursuivre cet échange avec
notre question du jour au micro trottoir
aujourd'hui est il plus difficile pour
une femme de créer son entreprise votre
avis on peut y avoir effectivement
quelques
quelques barrières à l'entrée mais
honnêtement je pense pas que ce soit
plus difficile
je suis chef d'entreprise donc ce n'est
pas très difficile je vous le confirme
après c'est une question de courage ou
on avance ou on reste tel quel oui c'est
plus difficile
c'est parce que justement c'est une
femme donc on pense qu'elle est pas qu
elle et qu'elle est pas assez solide
pour pouvoir
créer sa propre entreprise je penche pas
puisqu'elles sont débrouillarde côté
administratif je pense que c'est pareil
pour toutes de personnes je pense que
oui
parce que les conti dirais
pas encore comme les hommes c'est plus
difficile parce que je pense qu'on est
moins crédible aux yeux de fans et tout
ce qui est banques etc mais ce n'est pas
plus difficile on est aussi capable que
on parle de crédibilité justement
vis-à-vis des banques par exemple
comment ça s'est passé lorsque vous avez
fondé votre votre entreprise ce sont les
banques qui sont mieux voir voilà
j'avais un business plan j'ai présenté
il y avait deux banques qui sont
intéressés j'ai encore une fois mon
apparition du problème mais j'ai déjà
entendu à la problématique revenez avec
votre mari ça existe il est vrai que ça
existe ce qu'on essaye de faire
davantage au sein de l'association c'est
surtout de renforcer les compétences
d'apporter un soutien comme le chef
d'entreprise et multi casquettes que ce
soit sur l'aspect fiscal comptable
prospection ou métier on essaye
d'apporter des réponses et des
explications
alors ça peut être difficile parfois de
se lancer une fois que l'activité est
bien en route est-ce que quelquefois les
femmes doivent s'arrêter parce que c'est
plus difficile que prévu ou les
finalement les barrières ne se lève pas
les difficultés sont levés rencontre est
aussi très active par exemple il peut y
avoir des difficultés mais qui sont pas
forcément propre aux femmes les
difficultés économiques notamment que
les femmes rencontrées après les
responsabilités familiales on ne s'est
pas souvent sur les femmes plus que sur
les hommes
donc cette difficulté là c'est quelque
chose qui nous réunit tout devoir
s'occuper de tout à la fois arrivé à
hiérarchiser les priorités familiales
financières business ça a été compliqué
pour une femme vous êtes donc la
nouvelle présidente de cette association
femmes chefs d'entreprise créactive
quelles sont vos ambitions justement
quels vous apporter à cette association
va essayer de d'être davantage connue
sur le territoire on va d'abord essayer
de se rapprocher d'autres associations
qui peuvent avoir commandé entrepreneurs
et répondre à leurs demandes
différemment on a aussi un certain
nombre de créative qui interviennent
auprès des demandeurs d'emploi notamment
auprès du club face qui a et sur le
bassin donc voilà sont des
rapprochements avec des associations
locales qui permettent d'élargir un
petit peu nos réponses ou leurs réponses
en étant plus nombreux et plus vaste sur
les façons de répondre aux entrepreneurs
ou au porteur de projet on a quand même
un certain nombre de porteurs de projets
qui ont besoin de ce soutien au
démarrage il ya des projets qui se lance
justement alors au delà du fait ou non
un des deux femmes chefs d'entreprise
mais la situation économique est
difficile est ce qu'il ya des nouveaux
porte des nouveaux projets qui sont
portées que vous soutenez des femmes qui
viennent vous voir pour vous dire voilà
on va se lancer la crise nous fait pas
peur au contraire oui de très souvent
d'ailleurs c'est une réponse à la crise
de créer son entreprise quand on trouve
pas un job qui correspondent à ses
attentes on se lance on a des
compétences et on a envie de l'essayer
donc on a différentes porteuses de
projets au sein de l'association on les
dirige le plus souvent vers la maison de
l'entreprise de saint quentin en
yvelines qui répond très bien à ce genre
de demandes que ce soit pour le statut
ou pour le projet en lui-même pour le
financement également donc on a ce type
de partenariat pour
aider et soutenir les personnes à notre
niveau mais aussi savoir les rediriger
vers des partenaires plus concrètement
est équipé pour les aider par la suite
aujourd'hui créative ça représente quoi
combien d'âmes errantes on est une
petite cinquantaine d'adhérentes on
essaye d'ouvrir comme je disais à
d'autres participants quand on organise
nos soirées le but étant encore une fois
de se développer davantage d'avoir des
entreprises qui soit plus représentative
aussi du bassin local on est beaucoup
d'entreprises individuelles mais comme
je disais les femmes dans l'autre plutôt
pas forcément auto entrepreneurs mais
micro-entreprises crl et autres statues
mais souvent seuls 100 salariés et il y
assure le bassin des femmes qui ont des
entreprises de taille plus importante et
on aimerait les voir rejoindre aussi
notre association ce sera un axe de
développement pour votre mandat donc en
tant que présidente peut-être pour
conclure votre regard aussi sur
l'actualité économique à demain mardi
sera votée la loi macron alors ya dans
les grandes lignes il n'y a pas que le
travail le dimanche il ya aussi des
mesures qui visent à développer
l'épargné salariale pour les pme les
entreprises de moins de 50 salariés qui
n'auront plus l'obligation de publier
leurs comptes de résultats annuels par
exemple voici quelques-unes des mesures
qui seront mises au vote demain
qu'est-ce qui vous interpellent dans
cette loi macro est ce que vous en
attendez quelque chose où finalement ça
ne vous concerne pas beaucoup vous
auriez préféré d'autres type d'attention
la grosse demande des chefs d'entreprise
tout seuls dans leurs petites
entreprises c'est d'abord un allègement
des charges embaucher oui un jour mais
encore faut-il d'abord pouvoir se payer
pouvoir investir sur la communication la
prospection pour trouver plus de clients
est ensuite embauché mais encore une
fois aujourd'hui c'est pas la demande et
finalement ça correspond peu ça va pas
changer votre n'a pas changé notre
quotidien par contre
libérer l'économie et faire en sorte
qu'elle se porte mieux forcément ce sera
bénéfique pour les créactive merci
emmanuel plutôt non vous êtes la
responsable de l'association créactive
las de l'actualité de l'association
aussi retrouver sur votre site internet
qui s'est affichée merci on passe aux
sports à présent les championnats du
monde de cyclisme sur piste qui commence
ce mercredi au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines les
organisateurs procèdent aux derniers
préparatifs pour que le public et les
athlètes bien évidemment soient
accueillis dans les meilleures
conditions williams elle michael et demi
d'euros ont rencontré arnaud courtier
c'est le directeur général délégué à la
fédération française de cyclisme
cinq mille spectateurs par jour 300
journalistes 38 nations des chiffres qui
donnent le tournis cette semaine du 18
au 22 février le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines va devenir la
capitale internationale du cyclisme à
l'occasion des championnats du monde sur
piste pour accueillir les fans venus des
quatre coins du monde une organisation
millimétrée nécessaire pour ces cinq
jours de compétition tout est prêt ou
presque on en train de finaliser des
aménagements vous voyez peut-être un
petit peu derrière moi l'air centrale
sur laquelle on est en train d'aménager
sur le podium où cela les boks coureurs
pour toutes les équipes puis à
l'extérieur aussi bien sûr où on
aménagea un petit village de partenaires
sur le parvis on a installé des
conteneurs de stockage de vélos pour les
trente six nations où 38 d'ailleurs qui
vont participer au championnat du monde
et puis toute une infrastructure qu'on
ne voit pas forcément mais pour les
bénévoles les commissaires les
télévisions tous les gens qui vont
travailler pendant les championnats du
monde pour faire que tout se passe bien
dans l'air centrale située au milieu de
la piste le vélodrome dispose d'une
dizaine de boxe pour accueillir les
participants d'une infirmerie et d'une
zone pour les journalistes
sur l'air centrale tout a été aménagé
pour l'installation des équipes
premières équipes d'ailleurs sont d'ores
et déjà là installée et s'entraîne
donc là la zone dans laquelle sont
installés tous les journalistes pendant
la compétition
donc journaliste de presse écrite
principalement et si on se tourne de ce
côté là vous voyez l'étape dans les
tribunes qui sont les postes
commentateur télé des différentes télé
on a 20 ou 25 chaînes de télévision du
monde entier qui font l'événement
les aménagements extérieurs ont
également été effectués pour ces
championnats du monde des panneaux
promotionnels ont été mises en place sur
les routes à proximité de l'enceinte
sportive le parvis devant le vélodrome a
également été réaménagé pour la
compétition sur le parking d'un stade
quelques tentes dans lesquelles il y
aura les partenaires de deux lycées y
aura l'office du tourisme de saint
quentin en yvelines et puis un espace
france dans lesquels dans lequel le
public pourra se rendre aussi pour des
dédicaces avec les sportifs des
rencontres on va animer cet espace toute
la semaine y aura aussi des petites
choses à grignoter on est en plein mois
de février dont furent il y aura des
crêpes des gaufres de t-shirts chaude
comme ça pour un peu de réconfort le
vélodrome dispose encore de quelques
heures pour peaufiner l'organisation des
championnats du monde sur piste avant
que les vingt-cinq mille fans déferle
sur saint quentin en yvelines
et durant ces mondiaux de cyclisme tv
fils sera également sur le bord de la
piste pour vous faire suivre la
compétition analyses commentaires avec
notre consultant yann juge hardier et
puis également les meilleures chances
des français c'est à découvrir aussi dès
demain soir avec vincent jacquet c'est
le directeur technique national nous
irons à la rencontre de ces petites
nations du cyclisme les réactions du
public le travail du staff médical tout
sera à sera bien évidemment à suivre sur
notre antenne tout au long de la semaine
le week end dernier le lion's-club des
essarts le roi organisé sa 24e édition
du semi-marathon plus de 1200 coureurs
ont parcouru 21 km au profit des enfants
malades de l'hôpital bullion c'est une
bonne action et yolaine torres mélanie
poker
24e coup d'envoi du semi-marathon de
bullion ce week end plus de 1200
inscrits ont parcouru 21 km au profit de
l'hôpital de bullion les fonds récoltés
financeront en effet les ateliers de
l'établissement qui accueille plus de
130 enfants ou maladies rares et aux
pathologies lourdes certains d'entre eux
souffrent d'obésité morbide une
esthéticienne elle leur apprend à
prendre soin d'eux et d'autres projets
sont en cours là on va monter un atelier
couture ou du début jusqu'à la fin on
leur apprendra à faire un patron à
dessiner à faire du dessin de mode puis
ensuite à créer un vêtement pour là
encore travailler sur leur image et leur
redonner une certaine fierté vous
imaginez ce que c'est qu'une
hospitalisation sur du long terme
plusieurs mois voire plusieurs années
vient nous essayons d'amener des
éléments de vie kid dont il pourrait
bénéficier chez eux le lion ce club les
essarts le roi organisateurs de la
course depuis 24 ans récolte chaque
année entre 6000 et 10 mille euros pour
les coureurs chrono et performances sont
bien là mais il n'oublie pas la bonne
cause en règle générale d'une bonne
entrée dans ce sport à l'athlétisme mais
à lhassa mais vraiment du baume au coeur
et puis allez voir que si courageux sa
seule leçon d'humanité nous a des
coureurs en fait on est on a un
calendrier course à pied donc si c'est
l'argent
qu'on met dans la course si ça peut
servir une association schiste dans son
penchant pour certains enfants
hospitalisés ont également pris part à
la course grâce à des joëlettes et en
voir les sourires la mission semble
accomplie
samedi un chantier participatif s'est
tenue à magny les hameaux dans le centre
bourg une trentaine de personnes venues
aider robert pires et oui maraîchers
également installé des serres sur son
terrain mélanie poquet pour ce reportage
la pluie ne les a pas effrayés 30
bénévoles n'ont pas hésité à sortir
bottes gants et imperméable l'objectif
du jour construire de serre pour la
production future d'un marais chimène
quoi ce chantier il est symbolique
puisque c'est du maraîchage biologique
en plus quelqu'un qui s'implantent ici
qui craint un petit peu son emploi après
une reconversion n'a pas beaucoup de
moyens ça a été difficile donc je viens
pour l'encourager je vais pouvoir
bientôt profiter de ces légumes
c'est une bonne chose je pense de
pouvoir d'avoir des légumes de la ville
même plutôt que d avoir de plus loin et
puis c'est un pote donner un coup de
main tous ensemble
le maraîcher c'est lui robert pires il y
a quatre ans à peine il travaillait
encore dans l'industrie après une
reconversion et des formations il
obtient 10 hectares de terrain situés à
seulement quelques mètres du centre
bourg de la commune il ya un renouveau
de l'agriculture donc ça a du sens
ça reprend beaucoup de sens au sein d'un
collectif comme celui qu'on voit
derrière nous
puisqu'en fait ça c'est du lien c'est du
lien entre entre la ville et la campagne
entre entre ceux qui vivent de
l'agriculture qui produisent et ceux qui
la consomment robert pires a été retenu
par un comité de sélection regroupant la
commune de magny l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines le parc
naturel de la haute vallée de chevreuse
et le groupement a bien au sol avec cet
ensemble nous avons lancé une sorte
d'appel à projets et dans l'appel à
projets nous avons fait le choix donc
d'un candidat qui est robert pires en
fonction de la solidité de son projet
solidité viabilité économique
viabilité aussi par rapport
à l'environnement que nous avons ici aux
besoins en eau la structure de la
première serre est terminée
les prochaines étapes monter la seconde
les couvrir creuser les tranchées pour
que les premiers légumes soient prêts
pour le mois de mai
est les cultures urbaines derrière cette
appellation de multiples disciplines
danse musique graphisme ou encore sport
en plein essor depuis trente ans l
arrivée du hip hop les politiques n'ont
pas manqué d'accompagner le phénomène
exemple à magny les hameaux en fin de
semaine dernière à l'occasion du début
des vacances à rendez-vous dédiés
étaient proposées
plus de 70 enfants de magny les hameaux
présents au gymnase mauduit pour cette
première soirée de vacances scolaires
dédiés aux cultures urbaines un vendredi
soir autour des jeux vidéo mais aussi
sur un terrain de foot pour les garçons
comme pour les filles
depuis les années 80 les cultures
urbaines ont prouvé leur capacité à
innover mariage du billard et du
football voici donc le snow ball ça
consiste en quoi c'est un billard gien
en fait qui marche sur le principe du
football il faut dire que fait même le
même principe que au billard sauf congés
avec le pied tout simplement celui
stratégique physique voilà les services
jeunesse et sports propose ce rendez
vous depuis cinq ans il y à bien défi
sportif avec le football l'idée est de
rester festif avec des ateliers oui
c'est fédérateur ça fait longtemps qu'on
travaille à manille sur sur cette
thématique
justement dans l'objectif de d'intégrer
socialement ces pratiques sportives
culturelles qui parfois ne sont pas
connus par reconnu et qui qui peine à
trouver une existence et pour ceux qui
doutent du sérieux du message véhiculé
on rappellera la présence de
l'association humanitaire venu évoquer
son action alors en fait non on est une
association de développement durable en
fait où on part on finance des projets
de développement durable dans des pays
en voie de développement c'est à dire
qu'on a déjà fait plusieurs oeuvres
comme des poulaillers ou à travers la
vente avicole ces personnes à récupérer
des fonds pour faire tourner des écoles
emploi
prochain rendez vous avec les cultures
urbaines lors des vacances du mois
d'avril et le traditionnel festival
proposer toute une journée par la ville
c'est la fin de ce journal on se
retrouve demain aux mêmes horaires votre
soirée sur téléphiles c'est notamment
avec michael et demi d'euros pour une
nouvelle édition du 7 8 sport il sera
forcément très largement question de ces
mondiaux de cyclisme sur piste à demain